barry doublestone made his name as a
first class cricketer and international
umpire but in retirement investing
online
has caught him out last june he opened
an account with an online trading
platform
ofc markets for 250 pounds
within weeks the promise of apparently
huge returns and a hard
sell from account handlers persuaded him
to put in
50 000 pounds and he's on the phone
every second
day and you know a thousand is now worth
two and a half thousand
and uh so eventually the next thing went
up to ten
um and you know by this time it's worth
twenty um i think you see the pattern
and you got intoxicated by it but when
barry came to try and get his money he
couldn't
and began to suspect he'd been scammed i
went to withdraw ten thousand
i got an email back to say that the
withdrawal had been
received and all the process would go
through
and it'll be with me in three to five
working days
i'm still waiting for it for nine months
barry's been told he can only have his
money if he pays
thousands more in supposed fines and
taxes
in january desperate for his money he
agreed to hand over seven
thousand pounds ofc markets took the
payment
three times telling him the first two
transactions
hadn't cleared we listened as a salesman
tried to persuade him to hand over
another seven thousand pounds
to get his investment back you pay the
rest
of 7 000 of the fine and you get the
rest
remaining which is 84 000 euros
that that being that you receive
all your funds back it's infuriating
isn't it
the thing is it doesn't matter how
illogical they are
how big it is that they've got the money
they can say what they want
ofc market says it's registered in the
u.s marshall islands but there are no
names here
we took barry's case to the financial
conduct authority
which has issued a warning about the
website
they're not authorized by the financial
conduct authority to carry on that
business
so they look as though they may be doing
something that's unlawful
he'd supposedly made 100 profits now
that's a too good to be true return
which is a
classic sign of a scam the fca has no
powers to pursue cases overseas
but they want government to clamp down
on financial scams online
at the moment investment fraud and
economic crime is not
part of what is captured by the online
harms bill
it's not too late for the government to
uh to add it if it wanted to
the number you have called cannot be
reached at this time we tried to contact
ofc markets including the people
who've spoken to barry but they didn't
respond
lockdowns have created more
opportunities for online scammers
barry hopes speaking out will stop
others becoming victims
i'm not wealthy but it's not uh i'm not
suicidal
it's not the last penny i've got but for
some people it might be
paul kelsey sky news northamptonshire